-Guys, we have exactly
12 shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 days of
Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ 12 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we'll be giving one lucky
audience member
an out-of-this-world
Christmas sweater
from the "Countdown to
Christmas" cabinet.
Now, since there are 12 shows
left, let's open door number 12.
[ Drumroll ]
Whoa!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's see it.
Wow. Look at that.
Oh, my goodness.
That is unbelievable.
Wow!
Can we -- Is there a back to it?
Yeah.
Oh, wow!
Oh!
It's got, like --
It's got, like,
almost like
a Pop-Tart back to it.
It looks like a Pop-Tart.
I like it.
Very, very nice.
Let's see who is going to go
home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone, look at your
seat number, please.
If I call your number,
come on down.
And, Quest,
can I get a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
295!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Yeah!
-Whoo!
-That's what I'm talking about.
Oh, I'm so happy!
You go over there.
Hello!
I'm so excited that you won.
What is your name?
And where are you from?
-My name is Nadeesha,
and I'm from Midtown East.
-Welcome. Thank you so much
for being here.
Well, where did you say
you were from, again?
-Well, I live in
Midtown East now.
-Midtown.
-Midtown, yes.
-Oh, yeah, but east of Midtown.
-Yes, the better side.
-Be more specific.
It's like,
"What's your actual address
so we can all send you things."
No, don't do that.
But here in Midtown,
it does get a little chilly.
-Yes, it does.
-And we're getting ready.
Do you have a
sweater or anything like this?
-No, I don't.
-Wow!
Would you like to try it on now?
-Yeah.
-We'd all love to see it.
Wouldn't you love to see it?
Here's this...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Are you kidding me?
You are a knockout.
Look at this.
Are you joking?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, walk the runway.
You got it. Oh!
[ Laughs ]
You are a star.
Give it up for our winner.
A round of applause.
Stick around.
We're playing
"Off Songs, Song Off"
with Blake Shelton
after the break.
You look gorgeous.
I love it.
That's a rad sweater.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]